- [Instructor] When light is
going through a uniform medium,
like the air,
or as we know, light
can go through a vacuum,
so nothing at all,
we imagine it going in a straight line,
but we see something really
interesting happening here.
When it hits this glass prism,
I know it just looks like
a gray triangle to you,
but imagine it as a
triangular piece of glass,
and it's hitting it at an angle.
What this animation shows us
is that the path of the
light actually gets bent,
and not only does it get bent,
but the different frequencies of the light
get bent by different amounts.
Now, if you were to look
at this with your eyes,
you wouldn't be able to
see the actual waves,
like we're seeing in this
diagram right over here.
You would just see how
your brain or how your mind
perceives the various frequencies,
and that's why they made
the higher frequencies here
more like a violet or a purple color,
and that's why they made
the lower frequencies here
more of a red color,
because that's how your brain or your mind
would perceive them.
But you can see as this light goes from,
let's say the vacuum to this prism,
to this crystal or this glass,
the high-frequency light gets bent more,
and the low-frequency light,
which still gets bent,
gets bent less,
and then that essentially spreads out
all of the wavelengths.
When we have white light,
it has all of the visible
wavelengths in it,
but when it hits a prism like this,
if you imagine a triangular
piece of glass or crystal
and it hits it at an angle,
well, then the different
wavelengths spread out,
and if you were to put
a piece of paper here,
you would see a rainbow,
and that's actually how
rainbows are formed.
A bunch of water particles
in the air refract light
exactly like this.
This process of when light goes
from one transparent medium
to another, or a vacuum,
to some other medium
that it can travel through
that's transparent,
if it hits it in an
angle, it can get bent,
which is what we called refraction.
This is why when you
look at a cup of water
or at a pool at an angle,
you're not seeing
directly through the pool.
The image gets distorted.